hello everyone
and welcome back to the first session of
omics logic introduction to
bioinformatics program
this program is an introduction to the
field of bioinformatics or the
intersection of bioinformatics
and biology in this program
we will discuss the changing landscape
of data-driven research in life sciences
and the opportunities that come with the
widely
accessible high throughput technologies
and computational methods
for analysis and annotation of such
detailed data in research and industry
we will discuss various emerging
technologies
and their impact on health care
agriculture
environmental sciences public health and
more
my name is beepsha biswas and i am the
omixlogic community manager
responsible for daily interaction with
thousands of users
that are part of our bioinformatics
community
managed by pine biotech let me start by
introducing pine biotech the company
behind omix logic
share with you details about the
upcoming omics logic programs and
explain
how life training resources will be used
in the introduction to bioinfomatrix
program
over the course of the past several
years
our team has been collaborating with a
number of
academic institutions around the world
that have participated in content
evaluation
curriculum review and project design
as a result the omics logic programs
have been thoroughly evaluated
and are known to lead to excellent
outcomes
importantly the programs are designed to
support students with minimal
bioinformatics background
including biology and biomedical studies
majors as well as
faculty interested in bioinformatics
data science
and biomedical research the goal of the
omics logic programs
is to provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research guided by
mentors and pure example
developing a growing community with
shared passion for data-driven research
and appreciation of citizen science
enabling students clinicians and faculty
of
all backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research using latest
technology
in life and data sciences
in six interactive sessions you will get
to see
the broad applications of next
generation sequencing
biostatistics and tool for big data
analysis
in practical assignment we will be
learning about the logic of bipho matrix
and see how
data science methods can be used to
study biology
in conclusion you will also be able to
plan
how to take what you have learned and
apply them to an independent research
project using tools and methods we cover
in the program so this is the schedule
for the six sessions that are going to
be part of this one month program
and we will be discussing them in more
details
and now let me introduce you to the main
speakers of today's session
and the mentors of this one month
program
we have elia brodsky our
pine biotech co-founder and ceo in his
current role he has
extensive experience working together
with
industry and academic partners that are
applying
multi-omics integration and
bioinformatics to a variety of
biotechnology
and clinical applications dr harpreet
kaur
is a certified omics logic trainer and
expert bioinformatician who will guide
the hands-on sessions and
assist the participants with projects
and analysis
during the program her area of
specialization is cancer genomics and
machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is a romix logic
project mentor
and an expert in big data computational
analysis
dr mazumdar has a phd in computational
biology
and over 10 years of experience working
with industry and academia
and now i would like to pass it on to
ilia
to take over the session thank you
everybody
thank you and uh welcome everyone to
this first session
that will be focused on the very basic
introduction so we'll talk
today about processing and analysis of
high throughput data sets and some of
the logic behind
analysis pipelines we'll also discuss
some of the resources that you have
access to
in this program and how you can combine
the logic of bioinformatics with
practical skills
that are needed to succeed and excel in
big data analysis
my name is eliot brodsky i'm the
co-founder and ceo of pine biotech and
i'm excited to join you today
for this short program the program is
just
a first step and it's designed for
biologists
biology students for those that are in
clinical research
biomedical research but also those that
are interested in other aspects of next
generation sequencing
and big data in life sciences
so why so many of us are actually so
interested
in bioinformatics and data science
the truth is that biology is acquiring
the character of a data science
so many experiments are producing large
volumes
of heterogeneous information that needs
to be analyzed
processed and integrated to lead to
insights and discoveries and so the goal
of the omics logic programs
is to introduce biology as a data
science preparing biologists and
clinicians
for this influx of data that will only
continue to grow
and also helping them master the
associated methodologies
of data-driven research by focusing
on projects and understanding how
bioinformatics can
help us overcome the challenges of
discovery
and experimental design as we think
about
different aspects of life science
research
and industry so in this session i will
introduce
some of the topics that we're going to
be covering i'll talk a little bit about
the basic bioinformatic approach to big
data by showing
you how to run and analyze the outputs
from different pipelines
we'll talk about different types of
omics data because there's a variety of
different
information that they can provide
and we'll also talk about some of the
resources that you can leverage
in an asynchronous way after this
session
and during this whole program so the
course
that we're discussing here this program
and today's session
is really designed for those that come
from a non-engineering background
to introduce bioinformatics for students
biologists and clinicians
and understand how you can personally
get started
with your bioinformatics research
journey
so one of the important things that we
have to recognize
is that the influx of data
is continuously increasing in speed
variety and volume all the way back from
the 1950s when the genome was first
when the human genome was assembled up
until today
there have been new technologies like
next generation sequencing
that have produced continuously growing
volumes of data of different types and
have been made
publicly accessible and one of the
primary examples of that is the national
center for biotechnology information
the national center for biotechnology
information contains
different types of repositories and one
of them is the gene expression omnibus
or geo
which by itself contains over 80 000
publicly available data sets that
include
gene expression profiles of hundreds of
tissue types
in thousands of organisms across a
variety of different types of conditions
so we really see how the available data
opens up the door for those of us
interested in
handling these data sets and designing
hypotheses
driven by data that is already there
to be able to access high quality data
sets
that were produced by cutting edge
labs and in amazing projects that we can
all learn from
and leverage for our own study and
research
and that's what this program is going to
help you do we'll actually go on
ncbi geo sra
genbank and other repositories find
project data analyze that data together
and discuss the results the different
inputs and outputs of
technical pipelines but also
conceptually
we'll be able to look at the different
types of analysis methods that are
applied
to different types of data so what kind
of data
are we going to be talking about we are
going to be focusing on
biomedical research as an example
but you will also be able to apply this
to agriculture
biotechnology and basic life science
research
however in the field of biomedical
research
it's important to understand the
critical role that biomarkers
play in the diagnostic process
helping clinicians make day-to-day
decisions about their patients
including characterizing the disease
identifying the stage of disease
progression
and selecting therapeutics
this is based on the work of researchers
that can produce high throughput data of
different types to study
what happens at the subcellular
subcellular
level and importantly to integrate that
with all kinds of additional data sets
and repositories that exist
to describe the condition from a
clinical perspective
as well as to identify the specific
interactions
between proteins pathogens and hosts
as well as the different types of
processes that happen
inside the cell so this program is
designed to highlight
the role of large omics data sets or
big data that is shaping modern
biomedical innovation
where molecular data is used for
precision diagnostics
big data integration and machine
learning or transforming personalization
of treatment selection
and innovative algorithms allow for
unprecedented
capabilities with drug discovery design
of molecules and drug repurposing
so hopefully we will start talking about
all of these topics
today but before we do let me ask you
a few questions
so first of all what are some examples
of
omics data that is used in research that
you know of
okay so you can use the chat box just
write your answers
and later on we'll be using your
responses to continue and speak about
different aspects of the program so what
kinds
of omics data are you familiar with
that we have proteomics in genomics
joshua stephen is saying proteomics
okay we have sharma saying metabolomics
genomics transcriptomics excellent so a
lot of you
are familiar with the term omics
and for those of you that are putting in
answers like sra
or other types of answers really the
question here is
sra is a repository it's a database
but here we're just talking about the
different types of onyx interactomics
okay so it's very interesting to
consider
how many different types of omics are
going to be listed here so that's really
the point of this question so thank you
for answering this question
let me ask you another question related
to this
what kind of information can we learn
from transcriptomic data
so genova is saying gene expression
sequences differential gene expression
mrna
rna detail interactions mrna
gene genetic expression
excellent so let's think about
transcriptomic data so transcriptomic
is one type of data that you all
correctly identified it speaks about the
rna
mrna different types of small
rnas like micrornas long non-coding rnas
so transcriptomic is everything that is
being
transcribed so everything that is being
expressed
now studying gene expression data
we can look at levels of gene expression
and compare them between different types
of conditions
so that's called differential gene
expression we can look for
profiles of gene expression across a
variety
of classes of conditions or samples
we can also talk about transcripts or
isoforms
how genes can be alternatively spliced
in the process of transcription and
identify
differences in alternative splicing
between different conditions
and obviously depending on the data
preparation protocol
we can also explore other types of rna
that is being expressed
so i think it's important to understand
that we have multiple types of omics
data
and each type of omics data can provide
us with different types of
information let me ask you another and
final question for now
what are some of the challenges that you
know of
with analysis of omics data
ishwarya is suggesting accuracy
mutation data redundancy not much
exposure
precision false positive
repeated unwanted expression errors size
missing out on some data
data type and accuracy overlapping okay
so
there are some interesting challenges
that are being mentioned right now
in the chat box and let's
briefly summarize what is being said so
one aspect is technical
technical just the size of each data set
for example when we talk about
transcriptomic data we talk about
gigabytes or hundreds of megabytes per
sample
the bigger the sample set maybe tens or
hundreds of samples
very easily we can see how our computers
are going to run out of space
and run out of computational power
now the other side of it is just the
ability to annotate
so when we have a reference genome or
the transcriptome
when we have the reference genes and
their annotation
there's a lot that has to happen before
we can interpret with confidence and
therefore a large part
of part of the analysis is being able to
identify
the correct annotation databases the
right
references and link all that information
together
that the identified results could be
tested biologically
now it's also important what is
described here is that we're dealing
with
real biological samples so samples that
are being studied
in india or in china or in the us might
be
prepared in different ways sequenced at
different time points using different
machines
so there is a large variability between
the quality and the specific biological
conditions
that are being provided in a way that we
are
used to deal with data which is more
standardized
right when we speak about other types of
data for example
measurement of weight or height or even
clinical abbreviations for different
conditions and indicators
we're used to everything being
standardized and here when we're talking
about biological data and this high
throughput data that speaks about
individual processes within the cell
at a molecular precision we are going to
be facing this additional challenge of a
lot of technical noise and a lot of
biological variation so that's
what we will try to address in this
program
the program is going to talk about
data driven research in this age of high
throughput data in life sciences so
we'll look at a lot of these different
challenges that we talked about just now
we'll talk about the reference genomes
and how additional references and
changes to the reference
genome and its annotation can help us
understand
what is really going on we'll talk about
different
computer languages coding languages and
operations that can help us
find patterns in data and we'll learn
about effectively
launching different functions and
different analysis
algorithms to extract meaningful
information
and we'll also talk about this big
challenge of integration
of various biological data so that it
can be used effectively in research
as well as in industry applications like
in pharmaceutical
industry and biotechnology so
to do that we'll talk about different
aspects
of the way the data is generated
the way it could be analyzed from a
statistical perspective
and the way we can account for different
types of variations in experimental
design
so that when we are coming to
conclusions we can
go back and retrieve all the steps and
make sure
that the analysis is robust and
reproducible now many of these things
are
going to be applicable universally to
any types of biomix data
but as you probably will soon discover
handling
everything at the same time is going to
become overwhelming
so we'll focus on several examples and
instead of speaking about
theoretical approaches we'll try to go
deeper into
the project and really see how such
analysis decisions
can impact the results in the context of
very specific
examples i'll speak more about the
different project examples
in just a few minutes but before that i
want to introduce you
to a place where anyone can start
learning about bioinformatics
so let's go to a course called
introduction
to bioinformatics
introduction to bioinformatics is a
course
that is available for free on our
educational portal
so beeps have pasted a link in the chat
to access this course you have to
register and log in
for those of you that are part of the
program you should already be logged in
and i suspect that many of you have
already looked
at this specific course
so once you get to this course
sorry once you get into this course you
will see the introduction
to bioinformatics please put in number
one
in the chat box if you have reached this
page
this specific course is free and i will
speak about
some additional free courses in just a
second
and i will also speak about some
additional courses that we will leverage
in this program and they are packaged
within the program registration price
all right excellent so as you reach this
page again some of you might have
already started on this course
previously
but i want to briefly show you what
these courses
offer and how to best utilize them to
start with bioinformatics
so this course provides an overview of
big data in different applications of
bioinformatics
and okay so for those of you that are
here please make sure that you are
logged in
once you are logged in you can log in
with your email address
or you can register with your social
media
you will be requested to complete your
profile
and you will also be able to change your
password once you have completed the
registration
so once you're here you click on take
the course
and that's the way to get started now
this is a free course so anyone can get
started with it
and let's just take a look at what this
includes
so if you click on the curriculum tab
you will see that one of the first
things
is a survey and so the goal of this
educational portal is not only to allow
you to learn about bioinformatics and
start practicing applying bioinformatics
different data sets
but also for us to learn more about you
and connect with you so that we can
identify
the most efficient way to help you at
the place where you are
now after you have registered you will
have access
to the intro survey which we ask you to
complete
so that we can learn more about your
location your level of education
and the organization that you belong to
after you complete that you will be able
to see some examples
that show the data-driven discovery
paradigm shift
real-life examples in healthcare and
other types of
applications of bioinformatics including
environmental science
agriculture defense public health and
others
now after we go through some of these
topics we will also discuss
how to build bioinformatics pipelines
and we'll use
the t-biome for platform to illustrate
and do a demo
together so that everyone understands
how to get started
with bioinformatics and data sets
like genomics and transcriptomics
[Music]
so as i mentioned this course includes a
survey
and in the survey we're going to be
getting this information
reviewing it and getting back to you and
we will
also ask you to evaluate the content
what we've seen is that both students
and faculty find this course informative
and learn a lot from the variety of
types of applications that
bioinformatics has and the critical
importance
for biologists and others engaged in
life science research
now this course is going to talk about
the
emergence of big data that changes
everything it will show you some experts
that speak about their understanding of
bioinformatics
and the way that they affect healthcare
today
it will also help you learn the
terminology
and talk about different types of omics
data
and evaluate your understanding using
a quiz so here's an example
of that quiz now in addition to this
free course
we also have a number of other free
courses
on genomics and metagenomics and all of
them will be
introduction too so you will see
introduction to genomics
introduction to metagenomics so anyone
that is
learning about bioinformatics for the
first time
or is joining this program for the first
time we encourage you
to take some time to explore some of
these free resources
and start to really understand how you
can get
started in this journey of
bioinformatics
now in addition to these free resources
we are going to be leveraging some
additional
coursework that we have on this portal
and what's important about this portal
is that we are going to discuss
how the theoretical material that is
being discussed
could then be converted to a practical
application
of bioinformatics so for example in each
one of these courses on transcriptomics
we are going to discuss the process of
generating rna-seq data
analysis of rna-seq data for processing
where we get a table of
when we have a table of an expression
then you will get an introduction to
statistical analysis of rna-seq data
analysis of rna-seq data using machine
learning and data mining
and finally an introduction to single
cell transcriptomics
we will then continue on to explore
genomics
starting from introduction to genomics
calling in genomics 1 and downstream
analysis
of variance in genomics 2.
we'll also explore a variety of courses
on epigenetics or epigenomics
epigenomic data describes different
types of
dna methylation patterns as well as
histone modification that can help us
understand
non-dna encoded regulation
of gene expression importantly we will
also touch on metagenomics when we talk
about metagenomics we can study
a thousand of different microorganisms
or millions of microorganisms that live
in communities that
function and work together to affect
every aspect of our life
from immune responses to responses to
different treatments
and also the interaction between the
microbiome
and the different types of pathogens
so we'll talk about all of these
different aspects of different
types of omics data importantly every
course that you complete
comes with a certificate of completion
so those of you that are looking to get
a certificate
instead of joining the webinar and
looking for a certificate
you will be able to complete that course
passing the quizzes
and assignments and then you will be
getting
the certificate of completion for that
particular course
now once you get to that end it's
important that the certificate will be
generated
for your profile and so you have to make
sure that your profile is
complete in addition to some of these
resources
we will also talk about the practical
application of bioinformatics analysis
so you will see
bio data science is a selection of
courses
that introduce you to important types of
analyses
using r and python and you can also
explore
an additional portal that we will
utilize
during this the the next few sessions
called code.omicslogic.com
so i'll talk about that in a few minutes
but for those of you that are having
trouble
with the educational portal i invite you
to go to code.comicslogic.com
also a website where you can register
for free
and start exploring some of the same
analyses using
coding in r and python
the way these courses are organized is
they
provide with a clear outline
of what you might expect from joining a
course
understanding the terminology the
biological context the different data
formats
and understanding and analysis logic
you will also have topic mapping by
engaging activities where you will
understand how
the different theoretical aspects of
bioinformatics are applied directly
to the different data sets and in what
order and why
then you will be able to understand how
these apply to a very specific
data set or project so you'll be really
able to see project examples taken from
research publications and known
databases
that actually show you the specific file
formats in the context of a biological
question finally you will be able to
deploy an analysis pipeline and the way
that the courses are built
is first of all you learn about them you
practice with a demo
and once you've mastered the practice
you can start applying this
to independent projects that you can do
on your own
so after you get a certificate of
completion
of at least several courses that are
free or that are included with this
program
you will be able to access the practical
analysis that is offered on the t by
info platform
but you don't just start with analyzing
data without first understanding how to
apply it to a very specific project so
that's why
we will also talk about a variety of
different project examples
now in this program the introduction to
bioinformatics
for biologists we will take a few of
these examples
that are sourced from peer-reviewed
journals
in in high-impact biomedical journals
for example we will use modeling cancer
precision medicine
one of these projects is taken from a
publication
that was uh that was uh published in
genome biology called modeling precision
treatment of breast cancer
and it was published by a company called
genentech
company that invests heavily in applying
bioinformatics and machine learning
to large transcriptomic genomic
epigenomic and proteomic data sets to
understand
how different drugs interact and affect
different types of tumors in cancer
biology
in this particular study the authors
explored
the different omics data sets and how
they could help predict
the effect of different types of
therapeutic
molecules that range from the standard
chemotherapy
to more advanced immune
immunological drugs so to speak a little
bit more
about how bioinformatics is used in
cancer
research i want to invite dr harpreet
kaur
she is going to be participating in this
program
to help those of you that are interested
in learning about bioinformatics
and will share from her experience being
an
expert in cancer genomics harpreet
could you please share a little bit
about your background
thank you so just let me share my
life if you could please speak up
let me just share my slides
so hello everyone my name is harvey kor
i have a phd in bioinformatics my
research is on biomarker discovery
for diagnosis and prognosis of liver
cancer
so what inspired me to study liver
cancer is the high mortality rate of
this malignancy
and a lack of precise biomarker that can
help diagnose liver cancer
at an early stage it is sixth major
cancer
in terms of incidences worldwide
and fourth in terms of mortality
liver cancer is often at times
misdiagnosed
or detected too late for an effective
treatment
another factor that contributes to its
poor
outcome for the liver cancer patient is
the frequent reoccurrence of this
particular tumor
so with these concerns in mind
i frame a number of research objectives
with my collaborators to address these
issues
using bioinformatics
for the first part of
this research project we used last scale
transcriptomics data to identify a
diagnostic biomarker panel
for hepatocellular carcinoma which is
primary
liver malignancy so in this study we
employed 30 data sets containing nearly
4 000 sample to lucid day transcriptomic
biomarker panel for diagnosis
and prognosis of liver cancer
implementing
multiple statistical and bioinformatics
techniques
for the next part of this research
project
we use transcriptomics and methylation
data
to identify biomarker panel for space
classification
of hepatocellular carcinoma
here we employ tcga dataset
of 350 samples and elucidate
51 features that include
30 rna transcripts 21 methylation cpg
size
using number of data mining approaches
the navy's model classified early and
late samples
of hepatocellular carcinoma with nearly
79
accuracy
for the third part of this research
process
we use transcriptomics data to
scrutinize diagnostic biomarker
parallels
for chlangiocarcinoma which is another
major liver malignancy so in this study
we employed nine data sets containing
350 clengio carcinoma 133
adjacent non-tumor and 90 hepatocellular
carcinoma sample
to scrutinize clencho carcinomas
specific
transcriptomic signatures and here we
have employed
a number of data mining techniques like
extra tree
svm random forest logistic regression
lda etc
so in conclusion we have
identified a universal platform
independent
three gene based biomarkers that can
predict
scc patients with high precision and
also possess a significant prognostic
tension
then we identified a three gene based
clangio carcinoma-specific
transcriptomic signature
that are capable to discriminate cca
from scc and the normal samples
at last we identified a wire marker
panel
of 51 features that include 30 rna
transcript
21 methylation cpt site to predict the
hepatocellular carcinoma
at an early stage
so i am looking forward to vn your
mantle during
this introduction to the bioinformatics
program
and help all of you to learn about data
analysis
machine learning and visualization in
application to large datasets used in
biomedical research
in this program i will be speaking about
the role of big data
that plays in biomedical research that
can
generate a hypothesis that is then
analyzed
and used for accuracy improvement and
what this process is affecting clinical
cure
now i would like pass this session back
to ilya
so over to you
thank you harpreet and let's address
some of these questions
that are coming up in the chat as we
move on
so what's important about what we're
doing today
is this is just the first session in
this session we're giving you an
overview of what we will cover in
greater detail
in six additional sessions in the
introduction to bioinformatics program
we will
also introduce slowly step by step the
different
types of analyses and the different
types of project examples
so we will actually have experts like dr
harpreet kaur
and dr mohit mazumder who will be
speaking in a moment
help you identify data sets extract them
from
publicly available repositories like
ncbi
and run analysis that will help you
identify
biomarkers just like heartbreak or just
explained
so that you can try and do this on your
own
now in her research they focused on
liver
hepatocellular carcinoma which is a
particular type of liver
cells that lead to cancer so we will go
through
different types of cancers like breast
cancer
lung cancer liver cancer
and you will be able to see how the same
types of principles
could be used to work with clinical and
omics data
this program is just an introduction and
after a few more slides after we
introduce you to the practical tools
that we will be utilizing
you will also hear from dr mohit
mazumder about research projects
developed by previous participants of
the omixlogic training programs
that you will be able to follow and do
the same
as you make use of these different
practical resources
that we will be describing in a second
does anyone else have any questions
before we move on
okay so for those of you that would like
to still complete the registration
thank you for posting your email
addresses pizza will be
emailing everyone details on how to make
sure that your registration
is complete and you're welcome to email
marketing at pine.bio
with any types of questions that you
might have about registration or
links that are not opening
okay so let's continue speaking about
some aspects
of the program that will help you make
more use of bioinformatics and apply
clinical thinking to applying
bioinformatics different types of data
sets
okay and uh also for those of you that
are
interested in cancer biology i think
bioinformatics has
shown a lot of promise in cancer biology
and we'll talk about a lot of different
examples
that will help you understand how these
methods work
in real clinical settings as well
okay thank you harper all right so
uh what's important as you join the
program
is to make sure that you complete your
profile so each one of you gets a
personal profile so for those of you
that are interested in
doing more with this the interaction
during the session
is really to help you understand some
basics
but the work starts when you start
practicing
so this is not going to be interactive
in the sense that
you know 100 people can all talk at the
same time that i don't think is going to
be very useful
but what will be useful is when you
start applying
the methods that you learn to specific
data sets and we start interacting with
you
around the analysis challenges that you
might have to clarify
how to apply these tools effectively so
the first step is to really
complete your profile as you work
through the different coursework you
will receive assignments and those
assignments
include analyzing data which includes
running some bioinformatics pipelines
you will also see that a lot of the
courses have quizzes
and those quizzes are tracked so that we
can understand
where you are failing and try to make
sure that we understand and you
understand all of the concepts that are
being covered
and we also track your progress over
time making sure that you are actively
participating
and benefiting from the different
resources that we have made available
at the end of that process when
everything
is finalized and you have gone through
the different coursework and started
working on an independent project
you will receive a certificate the
certificate could be a certificate of
completion
or a certificate of excellence
so for those of you that want to
distinguish yourselves and really
showcase the ability to
analyze data the more you do the more it
will come up in your profile for example
in this profile you can see that sarah
zapiko who is
a faculty at university of florida has
reached over
18 000 points so anyone who reaches more
than 10 000 points will be able to get a
certificate of excellence
and also for those of you that complete
an independent project
will also get a certificate of
excellence now let me introduce you
briefly to some of the other practical
resources that we will leverage
during this program
this is another important part of what
we will do
actually applying big data analysis
to these data sets that we describe
about cancer
and other types of conditions so please
go with me
to server that t bio dot
info okay so maybe
put in number one in the chat as you
reach
this link server that t bio
info when you join this program
you will get a personal account on this
big data analysis platform
for those of you that are joining today
as
observers you will be able to use a demo
account so beeps if you could share just
the first
demo account details with those that are
joining us today
okay so those of you that already have
completed your registration
you should have gotten an email with
your personal account
your personal account contributes points
towards your own
account progress and for those of you
that do not have an account yet have not
completed your registration you can use
this demo account for now so again i see
that
one person has reached the server has
anyone else reached this server
and use the demo account okay great so
we have a few more
please let me know i will give it a
pause just a couple of
minutes until everyone reaches
so this is the t-bioinfo platform
it is a big data platform developed by
the tower bioinformatics research center
this is a research center at the
university of haifa
focused on development of novel
algorithmic approaches
to big data analysis specifically in
application to omix data
you will find that this specific page
demonstrates the different areas of
analysis including
next generation sequencing data mass
spectroscopy
structural biology and tools for data
integration
and modeling so what we will do today
is look at one example of a
bioinformatics pipeline
related to transcriptomic
transcriptomics so please open this
arrow
and go with me into this demo for
rna-seq data
once you're here click on start
and you will see that each button
represents
an educational resource where you can
learn about the typical steps
to process or prepare sequencing data
for downstream analysis the first step
is to clean up the reads
next generation sequencing produces
shotgun
sequences which means that they are
taken from random places
and all of the material that has been
shattered and
are sequenced in short reads these reads
could range anywhere between 30
nucleotides
and 350 nucleotides in length
they could also be different types of
sequencing including
single end or repair end this allows us
to increase
the accuracy of the sequence that is
captured within
each read as you look at the
pre-processing steps you will see that
there are a few different
options to pre-process this information
after it is processed and it is ready
for analysis
we perform mapping that mapping is
taking the short reads
and aligning them to the reference
genome
after those are aligned they have to be
quantified
so that we will be able to analyze the
levels of expression
for different genes
so let's click on ok and you will see
that some
additional steps are becoming available
so for those of you that are following
along now i can connect
the start button with the pre-processing
steps
the only available pre-processing step
at this point
is trim-o-matic trim-o-matic
is a mapping
it is a tool for mapping the reeds to a
set
of references that include technical
amplification and library preparation
sequences that will clean up
and reveal only the accurate read
information that will be used for
downstream
alignment and quantification
after you click on ok you can now click
on pcr clean
pcr clean addresses the issue of bridge
pdcr
amplification which can be biased and
can affect highly expressed genes
after i'm done with the pre-processing
steps i have a couple more options one
option
is to use mapping on genome to identify
different types of alternative splicing
events
or if i'm not interested in alternative
splicing and i'm
interested in gene expression i can
click on bow tie to t
which will map those reads on the
transcriptome
so only the express genes that are
recorded in the gtf file
again we will review all of these steps
in greater detail in our next session
and they are also covered in
transcriptomics one
so once i've collected the pre i've
connected the pre-processing steps with
mapping on transcripts
i can now quantify the gene
expression by producing a table of
expression
in read count fpm which is
fragment per kilobase per million or tpm
transcript per million
now the pipeline is complete i can click
on
end and
look at the output so here's the output
these are what's called table of
expression
and table of expression could be for
genes isoforms or
exons and you can also see an example
of a cell line expression data
normalized and annotated
as well as some of the clinical subtypes
included in this particular data set
so this is a quick example of what's
called building a bioinformatics
pipeline
so typically if you are a
bioinformatician you won't have to
launch different scripts like pcr
clean or trim-o-matic connect to
different databases
for example trim-o-matic uses a database
of technical sequences
or load in your reference genome
at the annotation file called the gtf
file
to eventually make sure that the file
structure goes from one step to the next
and produces the final output as well as
many intermediate
steps you will you will discover
very quickly that this is a very
intensive process
that requires high cpu power and
a lot of ram and storage
so for those of you that are going to be
joining the program
we will review in detail how to build
such pipelines
and also look behind the scenes on how
to apply
different types of r packages and python
packages
to perform what's called downstream
analysis
so on the t-bone for platform it is
built for research
tasks that require big data processing
and high performance computing after the
data is processed
after you have received the table and
you can start
analyzing the data you can turn to
statistical analysis
visualization and machine learning
so what we will do is go through
different
types of pipelines for different types
of omics data
and then extract the data that the
pipeline has produced
to start applying these packages using
coding what's important here is that
biologists and clinicians
are probably not as interested in
developing
proficiency in coding in r in python
but it is important for all of you to
understand
what goes into coding and how coding
packages and libraries are typically
used
to analyze visualize and share the
results
between participants of the web lab
and the drive lab so we have included a
number of courses
that you will be able to go through
including
analysis of sequencing data integration
of different types of data using
statistical analysis
machine learning different types of data
mining
or unsupervised machine learning and
supervised machine learning
and also annotation
so before we move on i want to ask
everyone if you have
any questions about what we cover and
i'll look through the chat to make sure
that i haven't missed anything
okay again i see that there are some
questions about registration
pricing how to register how to access
different resources
i think the best way to do that is to
register for the full
program and we will we will work with
you individually to make sure that you
understand how to access and also
how to leverage some of these resources
in a way
that you learn about bioinformatics and
learn to apply them to your own project
and we will definitely be emailing you
the links requirements for your own
computer
you don't actually have to have anything
more advanced than a chromebook
if you can download and upload files
that's enough
so you can actually process the data
sets on the cloud
so those are going to be the big data
sets that you process and then you can
use all of the uh different types of
analysis that we're discussing
here on the cloud so you don't actually
have to do any of it on your computer
you will benefit from doing some of it
on your computer so it's beneficial
to have excel or google sheets
and also to be able to upload and
download files so i don't think that an
android phone is going to be the best
option it's much better to have a laptop
at least at least a chromebook
okay and we've captured all of your
email addresses so those that have
shown in interest you could actually
uh you will receive an email from
marketing at pine bio
cloud processing doesn't need good
internet speed yes good internet speed
and reliable internet speed is going to
be beneficial
if you can join this session and see
everything that we are doing
in this session that means that you
have good internet speed enough for what
we are doing
okay so before we continue
we are going to give you an assignment
the assignment is first of all complete
your profile
on edu that t bioinfo so make sure that
not only you register but you put a
profile image
you write a little bit about yourself
maybe add some social media links
so that people can understand who you
are
join our social media groups which we'll
talk about in a second
and make sure that your profile is
complete then you can also explore
using this demo account or if you
already received your full account
you can explore the server.tbioinfo and
code.omixlogic.com some effective
practical tutorials
that we will be doing throughout this
program and
please complete the introduction to
bioinformatics course
fill out the survey and try passing the
quiz
so that will give us a good sense of who
you are
and how you are able to apply the
understanding of bioinformatics
different types of projects
can we run the r scripts in r studio yes
all of the scripts
in the omixlogic coding platform are
downloadable you can just copy them and
open them in our studio and we will
actually be sharing the r scripts
with you also from the pipeline itself
so now to continue speaking about
projects i see that many of you are
interested in cancer some of you
potentially might be interested
in other types of projects infectious
diseases and
others i want to introduce you to dr
mahitma zumder
he is responsible for partnerships and
is a project mentor in our omixlogic
programs
mohit please take it over
one second mohit needs to be
okay you you are co-host
uh area co-host is me so you have to
make mohit ghost
i did
oh that's you uh one sec
okay thank you and
hello everyone so let me just share
so my name is mohit mazumda and i am one
of the global representatives of fine
biotech
my phd was focused on developing a noble
method for sequence analysis using
machine learning algorithms after
working
on several bioinformatics research
projects i joined bioinformatics
industry where i'm collaborating and
working with
the academia and healthcare industry and
the pharma industry
to provide support for bioinformatics
research and training
but it's really exciting to be to be a
part of this
omixlogic experience as a project mentor
and to be able to work on translational
research with a diverse group of
students and
with diverse expertise more often
than not we hear about the biomedical
data being used
being used by pharma industry and
publications from
top research labs so as elia mentioned
there has been a remarkable shift over
the last
decade in the cost of generating
molecular measurements
so most impacted by this change in is in
the area of genomic medicine we heard
about
different type of cancers where it is
now possible to move from generating you
know
reference or population level data to
our you know individual level data so
now we
we are collecting uh that sort of
information and concurrently
there has been advances in development
of new algorithms and tools
to integrate and interpret this data
which is
what you saw uh the tbi info platform as
an example as well
so if you see this survey this latest
survey you will find out that ai
and big data have the biggest impact on
the pharmaceutical industry
however to understand
this application and to be able to find
information
from this big data it's important to
learn
about the analysis strategy and get
experience working on real data sets
so together with our collaborators from
top university we have prepared
tutorials for you
that takes you through a project-based
approach where we take data sets from
high impact publications and use them
for practical
exercises recently we finished a few
projects collaborating with students
researchers
and so
recently as i was telling you that we
finished a few projects
collaborating with students so all of
these projects
and applications were proposed by the
participants
so here is a picture of
if i don't know if my animation is which
is seen or not
so there are a few participants uh for
example
uh anurag who collaborated with our
agrabohra
and they worked on the infectious
disease project and people published on
different uh
platforms like linkedin and they got the
recognition
of that project being finished and
contribution
in that in that research area so for
example here ujjaya parikh recently
worked on her research fellowship
and her project on glioblastoma stem
cells
and uh continued her risk now she's
continuing her research
so um this is a link
let me share this and maybe let's go to
this link
so let me again share
the link
okay so this is the page when you get to
the project examples which are just
which is being just shared i guess
so this is where you will find more
relevant examples
[Music]
so here we talked about the guidelines
how do we go about a big data
bioinformatics project after you
get the learning and we talk about uh
pro
poster publication or going towards a
you know full-fledged publication
how do we reach a place where we have a
clear methodology defined in terms of
abstract
methods results and conclusion there are
some examples that we did recently
in collaboration with lbrn so you will
find those as well and
you will find the abstract and learn
from example so
some of the some of the participants
from
the infectious disease program and
research fellowship program
collaborated in a group so we uh we want
people
uh and this research groups to
collaborate so that they can
uh you know speed up this process of
working uh
on research and different people have
different expertise so they that helps
in
uh different aspects of the project so
this is a such an example
so after the project is
you know finished or it reaches a space
where there is
more conclusive uh information uh the
project is being recorded as a video so
you will find videos also
where uh the participants are describing
the entire project
and what is the outcome of this project
so here you will see
research on scope 2 as a part of
infectious disease
research project and then you will find
the research project that i just talked
about about glioblastoma
stem cells and the data available this
was all done through the publicly
available data sets
so you will find them in different
repositories that we discussed today so
there was an
interesting uh you know uh research
proposals that
we were evaluated and worked on
during this entire uh summer and
fall where people dis aware this
our participants and researchers and
faculty
and research labs so we collaborated
with
various research labs and faculty that
came up with
their own eye and
another example of uh from sarah
so uh sarah zapiko so you saw that uh
the certification as well so this is the
translational aspect of
your learning so please look at the
link and here i mean interestingly the
project based approach or the omics
logic
approach has been taken really well by
undergraduates
and high school students so we have
hannah hannah
davis here she is a high school student
and finished her bioinformatics project
working on our platform
you'll find more examples from high
school students
that those recently joined our genomics
in the virtual lab program
were able to work on their own research
project on cystic fibrosis
and another example from that program so
you will find the translational aspect
and what is the outcome one of the
outcomes of uh
these research projects by looking at
some of these examples
so with this uh i think
i can pass it on to miss biepcha she'll
be able to guide you with other aspects
like program registration
and access to various resources that we
discussed
today thank you everyone thank you dr
mohit
pallav if you have any question please
put them down
in the chat box so that we can look at
it
and get back to you
so this is the program registration page
i have already shared the link in the
chats
and i will be posting the link again for
everyone
it's called bioinfomatics.omicslogic.com
so if you scroll down to the site you
will notice
that all the different details of the
session are added here
and you'll be able to read some reviews
and i'm doing this one more time so that
all those participants who have joined
us for the first time today are able to
complete the registration
and to complete your registration the
process is very simple you either click
on get started or on pricing either way
this is the thing that pops up
and you can choose between three
options here so the beginner option
will give you access to all of the
resources that were discussed
in this session the intermediate
membership gives you access to all this
resources
plus a one-on-one mentor support
throughout the length of this one month
program
while the advanced membership gives you
access to the beginner
courses project stormix logic platform
and the tbi info platform
along with mentor support as well as
extra additional
30 more days to work on your project so
that becomes
like a two-month program for you so you
get an not only just one month
another additional month to work on your
project so this you can choose
according to your own preferences and
choices
and for those who are mentioning that
they would want to do projects
please leave any kind of requests that
you have regarding projects
at two marketing at pine.bio and we will
be reaching out to you
with your requests
and now moving on so once you are
registered
in this platform so if you scroll down
on this pop-up you'll see that there is
payment details
uh the advanced courses would require
you
to know the basics of biology as well
so we i will be talking about some of
the upcoming advanced
courses uh very soon so just to talk
about the
introduction to bioinformatics program
which we are starting
today the next thing once you complete
your registration what you receive
is your own profile so here i have dr
prashant mishra's profile
he is part of this program so you can
see that he has a badge
which determines that he's part of this
membership
he has been doing some of these courses
and
taking part in the coding platform which
is a code.org logic and he finished
some of the courses here so you see the
points that he has gained
so this is how completed profile looks
like it has a
profile image and a profile name
again you can again contact us marketing
at find.bio
for any kind of queries related to any
personalized projects
and once you finish your profile the
next thing that you have access to
is the organization page this is the
organization page exclusively available
only to mentors
and you will be able to see details
about the program
see the different uh syllabuses so
today we are on this first
session on 13th october our next session
will be on 15th october
and also if you scroll down below you
will be able to see all the different
participants who are joining together
with you
and their performance so we can track
everyone's activity
and not only this this organization page
will give you
access to courses that are part of this
program
so as elia was mentioning you should be
completing this is for everybody even if
you're not part of this program
you can complete introduction to
bioinformatics but you also get access
to other premium resources like
transcriptomics one two
then you have introduction to
epigenetics and more are added as we go
along
we also offer projects as part of this
training
so these projects are available free to
our participants
who are part of this training program
again and
these are asynchronous projects which
help you
in your own uh learning about how to get
started with the bioinformatics project
so these are the other resources that
are available to you
and we have a progress tab to track
everyone's activity so as
we are starting today
we see that the activity is just
starting out
so as we move on we will have more
graphs going around
so in a way we are able to track
anybody's progress
and help you go forward so even though
it will be
a group program program where a lot of
people are joining from different
uh fields of life sciences we are able
to
help each other and guide everyone
throughout this program
using this organization page and our
forum
yes the free courses sadesh also come
with
individual certificates so once you
complete a free course it will be
automatically generated not only just
the free courses also all of these
courses will each carry
their own certificates so you not only
earn a complete
program certificate but you also earn
one
certificate for doing each of these
courses
okay so that is there and
you can also see the syllabus on this
tab
okay sheetal i will be emailing everyone
the links to the free courses
after this session so that you can look
at them again
but again if you are on the edu platform
you can
just go to introduction to
bi-informatics
and start taking the free course from
here this is the first free course
as elia has been mentioning which is
available for you
and open to everyone so you can take
this introduction to bind for matrix
course
thus third thing that you have access to
is
the t bio info platform so this
we already had a demo section about and
every participant will get access to the
educational access to this platform this
platform is also available as a research
tool
that can be used by universities
research labs as well and individual
researchers
but for program participants they will
have access to five terabytes of data
in the space in the cloud so and they
will be able to not only work
demo pipelines but also some pipelines
which are shared
and you will also have access to the
code omxlogic platform
now for all of you who may be interested
in
advanced courses we have several of them
starting uh in the coming months
so somebody was interested in breast
cancer and transcriptomics so we have
this transcriptomics course starting in
december
we also have a program on infectious
diseases starting on ninth november
and data science is already ongoing
but it's still open for registration
through this week it has started
yesterday on 12th
october and we also have
another program coming up on
metagenomics so this is
the entire list of the programs that
are available for this year for those of
you who are interested in specific areas
which
are not covered under the program
yeah lisa i would like to address some
of the questions that have been coming
up
yes i just wanted to uh
show the research fellowship page just
one moment
you can actually start talking about
this as well
so let's start with uh dr
sheikh sheikh perat from chennai so
my area of interest is prenatal prenatal
and cancer genetics
i want to i want to i want the details
of ngs data analysis and bioinformatics
application
course so
dr sheikh we would
start this introduction to
bioinformatics course which will cover
all of these aspects that you have
talked about but
talking about your area of interest is
more towards
a research project i see there are other
questions
similarly on different research areas
such as forensic sciences and
nutrigenomics so
once you learn about the application of
the technology you can use it for
all these research areas finding data
sets relevant to
these research areas so the important
thing is is to understand the
application like
transcriptomics how to analyze
transcriptomic data genomics how to
analyze genomic data and what you can
find out of that genomic data
so if you already have a research
question so that
actually helps so you can look for data
sets that
are you know kind of helps in
finding those answers so that is the
kind of data-driven research
we are going to do in many of these
programs
and that's what our focus is to simplify
bioinformatics and big data research
because
doing this in without the infrastructure
is really
a challenge that we discussed and we
know about
so this platform and entire learning
experience
gives you that opportunity to be able to
work on some of those aspects that you
really want to
using the big data
so there is no certification for this uh
the individual session but you will
get certificates once you finish uh the
asynchronous course that we that we
shared so
uh the asynchronous course our
introduction to bioinformatics
introduction to genomics and
introduction to metagenomics
so these all courses are going to give
you an overview
like uh like the question to the
application of
uh bioinformatics and foreign foreign
sick sciences so
uh introduction to bioinformatics please
look at that course and
finish try to finish that course it's a
very simple course and introduction to
genomics gives you a
direction that what is all going on in
genomics what we learn in genomics
and then there is metagenomics so these
are free courses that are available
and that you can gain certificate from
after you finish those courses
so the question to such
to answer shah so shar please uh
email me uh yeah email
the the research area and the
research that you are interested in
and bioinformatics for neurodegenerative
diseases so we have
uh um we have uh
uh julia panoff she's a new uh
neuroscientist
and a bioinformatician working on
neuroscience
so one of our interns
and few of our interns were working on
neuroscience and data sets associated
with that
and some of them worked on alzheimer's
diseases
so we also have a project on alzheimer's
diseases so
you can work in neurodegenerative
diseases if you uh register for research
fellowship so that is another program
that is available
for researchers who are pretty much
aware of the census technology
okay santiago we will send you the
details of the research well this is the
research fellowship program yes
thank you so bioinformatics
machine learning pre-requisite knowledge
no this is where you can learn
joshua bioinformatics and machine
learning and application of
machine learning in big data informatics
especially because bioinformatics is a
really
big field because of its application
from structural data to you know genomic
data to different kind of data sets
so this is about ngs data and ngs data
you can
learn to apply uh machine learning with
this uh with this course introductory
course also
and associated material so there's a lot
of asynchronous material that guides you
through
how do you do ngs how do you do apply
uh gene expression machine learning on
gene expression data so that those all
those aspects are very simplified
and easy to learn through this platform
that's what
i have experienced so yeah
so internships are provided as a
research fellowship
program right now and internships are an
advanced internship is all is only
provided for those who
are expert in our platform so you have
to go through an omics logic platform
and
you have to show that progress
in your research in your learning to be
able to get any
kind of internship uh long-term
internship or a short-term internship
but the research fellowship program is a
program where you can work on your
project
and you have to take the only take the
license
for the t bind for platform currently we
are supporting the research
fellowship program ourselves so
just you have to look get the license
and
the sessions and almost logic training
and
everything is included in that
thank you dr mohit for answering the
questions
in the chats yes so everybody who has
left us an individual
comment on the different areas of
uh analysis and the different research
areas that you're interested in other
different programs please
wait to hear from us because we will be
individually looking into these requests
and even to sha if you had sent us your
email id
or sent us an email to us or left your
email id in the chat
please wait to hear from us we will be
reaching out to everyone
so that you can do something or take up
any of these courses or do a research
project with us which you
are interested in so thank you again for
joining today's session saying that if
you are joining this program
and the next date for the second session
of this program
is october 15th which is going to be
exclusively available only to our
participants
and you can join via this link
okay deepak we will be sharing the
fellowship link again
personally to everybody via email
so thank you again for joining today so
if there are no more questions
i would like to end today's session
thank you everyone
thank you everyone thank you everyone
okay if you are still leaving your
emails in the chat and if you have left
them before
we have a note of all of your email ids
and your personal requests so we will be
reaching out to you
and you can also request or send us any
information
or an email to marketing and find out
bio
for any other queries you may have
especially if you have
a research based query or a program
query
and you would like more clarification on
it so thank you so much to our speakers
today
and to our participants we'll see you
again soon
you